for thirty one-year-old fantage a lo de
car is a place of opportunity she's a
successful social activist who believes
her country has a bright future Fanta
founded Senegalese dream an organization
that tries to convince young Africans
hoping to find work in Europe to choose
Senegal instead one of those people is
Fantas neighbor buca she helped him to
set up a coffee shop yes with he's
educated unlike most young Senegalese
but despite his education he can't find
a job what do you do do you emigrate to
lie down and sleep no you get up in the
morning and do what you can who's
awesome i put it all down on paper i
presented it to them and they advised me
to do this and not that that this would
work out they found a place for me
thousands of young educated Senegalese
leave home to seek work abroad in the
past five months alone 1200 have risked
their lives trying to cross the
Mediterranean by boat Senegalese dream
convinced buca to stay and supported him
in getting the official documentation
and in drawing up a business plan
seventy kilometers outside of Dakar in
schools all around the country Fanta
engages with the young generation for
her entrepreneurship and agriculture are
the answers to the job crisis Oh viola
they prefer to go sweep the streets of
Amsterdam to go sweep the streets of
Berlin or Barcelona than to work the
soil here because they think that this
is already success when they come back
to the car they're wearing a suit when
they get off the plane the cousins carry
their luggage and they marry the best
looking girls in the village because
they're an immigrant they only stay for
a month into car and when they return
they're sweeping the streets of Berlin
again
we need young people in Senegal who are
aware of the role they have to play here
and not a generation that dies in the
shores of Spain coming from a modest
background Fantas family wanted her to
work in France but she went to
university instead and got a scholarship
with a german konrad adenauer foundation
after that she became a deputy mayor in
Dakar Fanta is my role model I want to
be like her I want to finish school
Mamadou mokhtar does not share Fantas
vision despite having an education he
could not find employment in Senegal for
years the disillusion 35 year old
Senegalese took a boat and tried to
leave but the Spanish coast guard
stopped him he says he'll try again to
get to Europe girl never knew I don't
want my son to live like me yeah I want
a brighter future for him I don't think
that things will get any better for me
here in Senegal there is dec pull a van
Segawa these are the stories fanta faces
every day but the flight to europe helps
neither the country nor its people